I said I'm nice thinking and wake up
every morning checking my phone
measuring my life and self-worthing one
of all numbers
thinking about all the things I want to
do that I must do always thinking about
my next step wake up work more you're
not good enough sleep less work faster
work go to sleep wake up Do It All Over
Again One Week passes more coffee more
cigarettes more distractions from my
thoughts and from my emotions there's
always something that has to be done
before I can offer myself the time to
feel the time to accept myself
I had to do more sleep more eat
healthier exercise be more social work
more be better in every aspect of life
is not enough we'll never be enough
don't stop can't stop right now dude
model will be better
I need more and more of everything and
only afterwards I will feel safe
and accepted
because how was I supposed to fill up
the emptiness inside of me if not with
achievements or with material objects
just one single problem
there was never enough I was never
satisfied
I was aching hair was filling my heart
waking up stressed every morning I
caused the pressure every day on being
perfect
I couldn't allow myself to be I couldn't
accept myself
I created for myself the perfect trap of
feeding my vicious beliefs a voice
behind my back always Whispering you're
not good enough and you will never be
never good enough to offer myself
appreciation or compassion no empathy or
understanding for my own being
it's the mining behavior in which I keep
raising the bar high for myself so I
keep wanting more a clear path to
destruction and I was aware of it a
continuous roaming of the mind and own
endless maze until it meets the door
collapse
my own bubble of comfort whose walls
used to offer me safety that was
starting to constrain themselves onto me
slowly cutting my breath making me feel
significant more and more day by day
today it feels like the only safe space
I have is my own room but actually it's
my most dangerous trap created by
comfort and which will lead me to my own
destruction so I'm escaping skipping the
batter which was filed me down in a
deeper emotional numbing and less
self-awareness of how I'm neglecting
myself until one day I won't be able to
wake up anymore and I'll be completely
alone
[Music]
this is a story of anxiety and how
workaholism is destroying my life the
story of addiction many of us are living
in one form or another and how I started
to escape workholism
in the short movie I want to open up a
little bit to explore and present my
addiction which is workaholism while
showcasing some shots from my trip to
Bucharest using the Sony film simulation
picture profiles
if you're not familiar with Sony film
simulations they're in camera picture
profiles meant to give you great colors
right on camera for both video and photo
modes
I have a full playlist on this subject
so you can go check it out on my channel
I just purchased the sigma 24 F2
contemporary which is an absolute Beauty
and want to test it out in a more lively
context compared to my hometown which is
a very quiet place so I decided I needed
something new a new environment to push
me out of my comfort zone out of my room
out of my apartment to see everything
with A New Perspective something to fix
me into the moment and what better place
than a capital city so I plan my trip to
Bucharest
woke up after sleeping 12 hours in the
chair got up the train half asleep
everything seemed like moving slowly and
fast at the same time sun was Rising
rapidly without patience and people were
hurrying up to find their place so I
anxiously followed the flow and started
searching for the first moment to
capture
[Music]
I had multiple film simulations that I
wanted to Showcase in this video like
Dakota Chrome 64 Hector 100 cine steel
50d xenovo light Kodak gold and
cinechrome but after trying out the new
cine Chrome film simulation I just fell
in love with it and I stick with it most
of the time
I'll put the name of each film
simulation under so you can decide for
yourself which one is your favorite
the footage was all created using my
film power grades which you can find on
my website but the photos are straight
out of camera to showcase the colors and
the image you can get without any
editing just by using the Sony film
simulations
I had all these film simulations and I
didn't know which one to start with I
felt overwhelmed trying to decide which
should best fit the situation or at
least mirror my own mood
but what was my mood
what was I feeling
actually don't know because everything
was masked by a feeling of overwhelmness
this morning people are in action the
sun is low creating interesting shapes
to work with and as I was walking I took
a couple shots in my frenetic
inspiration to capture something
[Music]
but it all fell off
couldn't focus and I lost so many
moments so I panicked I felt like
between two walls we seemed to get
closer to each other in an alarming
state
I was supposed to come together with two
friends but they canceled so I ended up
alone which made me even more anxious
more paralyzed
I couldn't gather the courage to go out
alone
I was in a rough doing the same things
every day and consciously engaging the
same unhealthy behaviors ignoring the
signs my body and my mind were giving me
[Music]
I was living just like a Mindless robot
even though I'm still young I never felt
as old and helpless as I did in this
moment
I couldn't control my life I had no
energy to take responsibility for my own
decisions so I was piloting this body on
auto mode I was living inside of
Illusion hoping things will get better
without me trying
it is so stupidly simple something I
used to do with such ease in the past
now seems like a huge wall which is
impossible to be climbed
[Music]
I'm not even capable of leaving my home
to exercise in the park or to take a
walk
what about leaving home to visit another
city all by myself
this was a bad idea
why am I feeling like this shouldn't be
such a big deal I've done this so many
times the past why is it so hard to do
it right now I feel lethargic and I feel
shame I feel like a failure like I will
end up being nobody because I keep
feeling more and more anxious more
overwhelmed of life and all the changes
going on these days
foreign
[Music]
I
cannot feel safe around my closest
friends I can barely feel safe with
myself alone and that for how long
how long till I won't be able to handle
myself either
well you know what
I'm done feeling bad I'm reframing my
life to a New Direction
I'm still scared as hell but I choose to
go I choose to jump into the endless bit
of anxiety
[Music]
as the rush hour was on decline there
were less and less people on the streets
and the sun was Rising menacingly
it already seemed pretty bad I just got
there but already felt like I'm behind
schedule there was not much to do
felt like a bad start of the day but I
didn't want to quit
subtly the voices out of my head stopped
me and reminded me why I was there
I came to relax I came to experiment
there's no final destination to reach
there are no goals to achieve
is only me and time time to explore so I
dialed in the settings for cinechrome
which was never tested before in the
field and it started to give myself a
moment
[Music]
I slowly calmed down and start to feel
the city
everything started to fall into place
slowly everybody Refugee in their own
affairs
most of them working some starting to
find Shelter From The Burning sun which
was looking more and more menacing as it
was rising up over the endless Concrete
Jungle
so I was wondering where can I find
people and stories at this late hour
I just walked around taking shots of
buildings waiting for something unique
to happen
something out of the ordinary
[Music]
people say Bucharest is a concrete
jungle and it's true but I was amazed to
see how many parks and green spots they
had
every street must filled with trees and
every Zone had at least one huge Park
I started losing track of my map I just
heard around being attentive to
everything happening around me
and suddenly my anxiety melted and I was
in touch with my surroundings
[Music]
it just clicked I just realized one of
my most valuable lessons for street
photography up to this moment which is
industry photography just like in life
in general it's not always about moving
around hunting frenetically for the next
moment the next hype sometimes is a
calling for meditation for being still
in the moment in the same spot and
without realizing the beauty of life it
wraps before you
there is a certain charm to the city to
the streets the people
everybody's open and so friendly
[Music]
coming from a small town where people
look oddly and certain at you if you
have a camera around your neck Bucharest
was loving if they should playfulness
how the lights fall on the streets the
architecture the shops the smell of the
people when they realize you took their
shot there is a certain magic to the
city and they all seem to be enjoying
being part of the process as much as I
did
it's my second time visiting Bucharest
and I absolutely love it
[Music]
unfortunately I won't use too many
pictures but recognizable people because
I don't want anybody to be offended
I try to ask most people if they mind if
I took their picture but I never asked
them if they'd like to appear in my
video
so to respect their identity I will post
only pictures of unrecognizable people
foreign
[Music]
ly I realized I was enjoying myself and
I started shooting absolute random
nothingness
[Music]
after walking around in circles for a
couple hours I came to the conclusion
that it's time to move to another Zone
[Music]
foreign
so I shelter in one of my favorite parks
everything starts to move slowly and
gentle time feels like taking a break as
well in this sunny day and everything
starts to feel a little bit more
colorful in my eyes
[Music]
I just walked around observing
birds chirping people were relaxing in
the shade somewhere sunbathing and kids
were playing
it was a very calm place to be
I really love these shots seeing these
kids playing reminded me very much of my
own childhood and how I used to play in
the summer time with pretty much
everything I could find
everything felt different in those times
no worries on my mind everything seemed
to move slow and my heart was built with
curiosity to explore
nowadays it's hard to reconnect or feel
the same
but I'm also different
but even though I'm different now
maybe it's time to reconnect
[Music]
after quiet and relaxing stroll through
the park I decided it's time to explore
new areas
there's something about public
transportation that really makes me feel
excited especially a Subway
maybe it's the lights maybe the changing
levels of underground the smell of
basement maybe how the wind is blowing
like the storm is coming
and the stories obviously the stories
I just love it all
probably no place holds as many stories
as a Subway they've seen it all
when you were rushing late in the
morning when you were having a good
laugh being drunk with your friends on a
weekend night
when you smirk because you received a
text from somebody special
but also when you were alone and when
you held inside the tears because there
was nobody to hold you
it's all in the subway
I love observing and taking part of
stories it's where most inspiration
takes form a place where you can start
to feel and understand
that we are all people fragile and
vulnerable human beings and sometimes
that's all we need someone to listen and
to understand us but instead we are
thought how to be strong individualists
how to be heartless how to ignore our
emotions and leave our human traits
behind because it only shows weakness we
need to be helped not pushed down
[Music]
thank you
foreign
I was shooting mindlessly it was such an
easy pleasure
walking around everything seemed of
interest to me not regretting at all
knowing that I was going to spend hours
and hours deleting the useless shots
that I've taken
[Music]
I feel so free with all my Warriors
melted
everything seems so real and in place
just like it's supposed to be
I was seeing something unique on every
street and it was the first time I felt
so inspired in so long
I wasn't just a ball of anxiety anymore
my mind wasn't overreacting and
overthinking everything
it was Stillness
[Music]
and finally I felt connected to my inner
self
coming here alone was not a mistake
and clearly it was not by chance
it was all part of my journey of
reconnecting it was my liberation
[Music]
as the sun goes down the envious of the
city changes as well people starting to
be less friendly and more skeptical of
any interactions especially in the areas
that I wanted to explore which were
pretty dangerous night time
[Music]
I myself became more aware of what is
going on around me since the ambience
changes from block to block
and subtly sketchy folks start to appear
on the streets
Wall Street can be peaceful with pretty
houses while the next spot full of shady
people roaming around
overall it felt great rivers in
Bucharest and the strip was exactly what
I needed but with empty streets and
nothing going on it's slowly getting
boring so felt like it's time to go home
but one funny thing is I wanted this
trip to be as spontaneous as possible so
I decided last minute to leave and I
didn't check what time is the train
returning hometown
usually there are trains every couple
hours so didn't take into consideration
my next train will leave only the
following day at 6am
it was 11 30 pm and overall I've been
walking for 18 hours straight I was
really tired my body was aching for
sleep and I still had more than 6 hours
to wait until I could leave Bucharest
so to speed up the remaining time I went
back on the street
but out of the sudden everything changed
completely and got really creepy
foreign
[Music]
passes by shooting mindlessly listening
to the streets being aware of every
sound happening around me
but with streets being completely
desolated and at times weird people
being from nowhere
I didn't feel that comfortable anymore
walking all by myself
[Music]
foreign
was also closing so I had to take my
final ride for the night I wasn't aware
of this aspect either I thought I will
be able to travel with the subway all
night
unfortunately the last stop was not
exactly at the train station
I was in a rather dangerous part of the
city at around 1 2 A.M and I had to go
by foot all the way back to the train
station
coming out of the subway I noticed
people with spring and distance and
groups of people rapidly disappearing
behind corners
it was all pretty sketchy
suddenly two guys appeared riding their
bike strangely close to me
everything seemed rather uneasy and I
was very cautious of my surroundings
it was also silent
there was nobody in the streets only
some cars passing by
[Music]
there was no restaurant or fast food
open no place to waste my time in safety
until the morning comes
I eventually decided it would be safest
to go back at the train station and wait
for the morning to come
so I walked back to the station and
waited there together with a couple
people who were also commuting to
Bucharest from smaller cities
they were also waiting for the night to
end
I spoke to one guy he was such a kind
soul but very unfortunate
for the last three years he has been
working without any Contracting
Bucharest as a daily worker business
owners come pick him up together with
other job Seekers and they promised them
work for maybe one day sometimes one
week or if they're lucky one month but
many times he finds no work for weeks so
he stays in the train station homeless
because he has nothing better to do in
his small town he believes he has no
other way of earning money and he will
never find a good job because people
won't hire him he wasn't sure if he
should stay one more day or not
he had five bucks left that was all his
money which was his train ticket money
he didn't beg for money he wasn't trying
to use the story for me to pity him
I could see the sorrow the honesty and
the truthful of this man I pursed him
and he just opened up to me which I
appreciated
you deserved more but he couldn't see
the opportunities he could have
his story really touched me so after I
gave him some food money and my goodbyes
I started reflecting on how much do we
need to lose in this life to realize of
what we had in front of us
his story made me realize how ungrateful
I can be at times and how much luck I
had in comparison to others to have the
life of mine or at least for the chance
to be aware to be able to choose New
Perspectives
just because I knew I had a choice and a
chance for a better life the luck of
having hope to change things hope which
this man had no more
it's not much but even this little
awareness is such a privilege
it's never our job to judge and bring
people down we try to help them be their
best little by little because that's why
we become addicted and Ill minded and
angry and mad because we cannot relate
to one another because we feel so
misunderstood because we feel like we
don't belong
and because we cannot stand each other
but what if we just stop for a second
and listen to the ones close to us
realize we're all humans we're not
perfect
and will make so many mistakes and that
is part of the process so instead of
separation and hate let's try to
understand each other because that's all
we seek as humans we seek appreciation
through various forms his incompassion
our most powerful tool in resolving
problems and overcoming our own ego
compassion towards yourself and towards
the one around us understanding which
fulfills The Emptiness or trauma left
behind
more than achievements More Than Cars
Rings clothes and material objects
only if we allow ourselves to be
vulnerable and A New Perspective arises
the new world is built right in front of
us a world of humanity and connection
a world where we make mistakes but a
place where we also fix what we've
broken and a place to exists with all
our differences
for everybody to be together in a
community
hopefully this video helps you see A New
Perspective share the message and thank
you for watching
foreign